i need a minute
bring the car around
yes sir agent sitwell how was lunch i
hear the crab cakes here are delicious
who is this the good-looking guy in the
sunglasses you're at 10 o'clock
your other 10 o'clock
there you go
what do you want you're gonna go around
the corner to your right
there's a great car two spaces down you
and i are gonna take a ride
and why would i do that because that tie
looks really expensive
and i'd hate to mess it up
[Music]
tell me about zola's algorithm never
heard it what were you doing on the
lumarian star i was throwing up i get
seasick
is this little display meant to
insinuate that you can throw me off the
roof
cause it's really not just style rogers
you're right it's not
it's hers
oh wait what about that girl from
accounting laura
lillian lip piercing right yeah she's
cute
yeah i'm not ready for that
zola's algorithm is a program
for choosing insights targets what
targets
you the tv anchor in cairo the under
secretary defends a high school
valedictorian iowa city
bruce banner steven strange anyone who's
a threat to hydra
now or in the future in the future
how could it know
how could it not the 21st century
is a digital book zola taught hydra how
to read it
your bank records medical histories
voting patterns emails phone calls your
damn sat scores
zola's algorithm evaluates people's past
to predict their future what then
oh my god pierce is gonna kill me what
then
then the inside helicarrier scratched
people off the list
a few million at a time
you